hello uh Netflix not your Witcher
anymore yeah have fun with Liam
Hemsworth cause I'm out Superman is Back
was it was that too harsh wow I don't
want to burn any Bridges oh one second
I'm just glad that we're totally 100
confirmed on Superman 95 sure 100 we're
like 50 sure so okay
apparently you're not Superman um that
is so silly of me I should have I should
have double checked I thought this was
like a like a done deal I know I know
I'm sorry okay why did I post on social
media that I'm back at Superman I mean
do you really need to be Superman I mean
you have The Witcher I mean oh shoot no
you just called them I'm literally Built
For This role man I mean if I can't do
this then then what can I do I mean uh
Riverdale you like Riverdale I could get
you on Riverdale what is that um young
Sheldon you could be one of the one of
the uh guys on young Sheldon that that
show is huge no you know one of the one
of the guys on young Sheldon like young
Sheldon get off my get off my porch you
know that's those kind of guys no shoot
I'm stuck I feel bad I'm sorry what do
you want do you want me to forgive you
like what you know what Henry we love
you
you'll land on your feet and I cannot
stress this enough
uh oops right